hi my name is erica Hill and talk loud
this is my partner dem investor check
but what we wanted to do was make an
apparatus that would be able to produce
ethanol much like ethanol plants in the
Midwest but we wanted to make it so that
individuals would be able to make their
own feel to use in their only 85 and
engines and by doing this we wanted to
make it as simple as possible for the
consumer so we use all electrical
solenoid valves and electric ball valves
views that electric heating source using
clean elements plug it all into a
microcontroller and this allowed us to
turn on the different devices at certain
times than the ethical making process we
really wanted to make it for the farmer
that's
main application was for that the fire
could use it in his own farm production
that uses wet or damaged torn
the whole process of fraud you can use
commented grains was five stocks that I
think
loose out of all the vibe
we ended up for each batch that we did
we ended up up about two gallons of
seventy percent alcohol which is
flammable we did try he that can sustain
a flame we believe that if we focus on
the fermentation and a few other aspects
we could actually get that up to four
gallons of the closer to eighty percent